I want you to notice for this triangle
this could be any triangle I've called
the lengths a B and C I've called the
points the corners the vertices are
called them capital a capital B capital
C can you remember why they are where
they are why are they there they are for
example if he is that's be sorry that's
B then I put the lowercase B the side
opposite very good okay you remember
that's important yeah I could have I
could have renamed it which will become
important in a second okay so I want you
to remember last time we developed this
formula and it told us about the area of
this triangle do you remember that so
what I want us to do especially if
you've got another color better is I
want to highlight the features on this
triangle that way music okay so have a
look say yeah yeah yeah in fact you can
see it's over here on the right hand
side my page that's because I'm going to
draw some other stuff on the left there
show them okay if it's on the left it's
fine
I have a look where are the features
that I'm interested in
here's one of the sides there's a here's
another one of the sides they'd be now
importantly and some of you asked me
this during the review questions where
is the angle that we're using it has to
be in between and we have that special
word that starts with an i we call it
the included angle right because it's
not a social blown up so we need to uh
we need to mark that in so there's C and
if you've got colors maybe you want to
UM fill that in as well now here's the
important thing I want you to know in
this example I actually have all this
different information at my own at my
fingertips so half a B same C is not the
only way that I'm forced to actually
work out the area of this triangle
for instance and sorry that I'm doing
this quickly but you can draw another
way if you take the same triangle
instead of picking a and B
say for instance I picked yes please say
for instance I picked a and C so I've
got that's a pool color choice sorry let
me do that again if I had these two
sides here which angle would I use I
would use the one between them which in
this case is B okay
so again I'm gonna draw that here okay
yes yes please yes please now because
I've used different features here the
way I state the area formula will be
ever so slightly different it's not
gonna be half a B sine C it's gonna be
half AC sine B different sides different
angle ay C sine B now I promise this is
last time I'm gonna ask you do it but
there are three angles to choose from so
if I've used two of them so what's the
last possibility that I have left which
pair of science which allowed me to use
bait B and C right I haven't used that
combination yet B and C which of course
means if I'm using those two sides then
the angle must be a down there in the
bottom okay now for the third and final
time if I choose those features instead
I will write the formulas slightly
differently I'm gonna say not half a
b-side C but half B see sign a okay I
promise no more drawing now now here's
the important thing why did I ask you to
draw this three times here's one well
number one there's only three ways to do
it that's it there's no other
combination that you could use but more
sort of and it will meta-level right
mathematicians do this all the time
trigonometry and our study of it's not
really right now about trains
it's about approaching the same problem
from multiple different angles and every
time you look at it a new way you learn
something new okay and this is just a
principle in life you've got a problem
to solve try approaching it from lots of
different perspectives and you gain
something here's what we're gonna gain
this time what was i working out again
its area right but it's the same
triangle every time so therefore no
matter which way you look at it all of
these areas are the same value do you
agree okay so I know this is a bit weird
we usually say equations you gotta have
two things left hand side right hand
side but you've got three things they're
all equal okay so you okay with that
and just like all your normal equations
it's fine just like all your normal
equations if you do something to one
side you can do it to all the rest that
everything stays fine okay
so he's the first thing I do wanna do I
wanna simplify this a little bit see
there's a half out the front of each of
those what can I do to all three parts
to get rid of the hub I can multiply
everything by two I'm gonna do that if I
multiply this by 2 and this by 2 and
this by 2 okay my next line is gonna be
BC sign 8 AC sine B and then the one we
started with a B sine C now this next
bit this is the last step of working
really maybe you wouldn't guess at it
but what I'm trying to do is see how
patterns that flows all the way through
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to divide every one of these parts
by a particular term the same time every
time I have to do cos are all equal the
term I'm gonna choose and you might not
have guessed this is a and B and C
multiplied together every single time
now if you do that I want you to watch
what happens
have a look just look at the first one
on the Left what terms cancel B and C
they're gone there and they're gone
there what about in the middle the the
AC cancels with the a and the C you
agree
it's different that's that's all about
an angle yeah last one what cancels on
the right type the and the B they've
gone
okay so now I'm gonna write this all
neat and tidy with all without all my
cancel things what I find is that if I
take sign of vening whatever it happens
to be and divide by what's left
it's a but which a is it because it's to
eight it's the lower case which is the
length right that's the load that's
gonna be equal to sine B that's the
angle divided by what's left on the
bottom just the little B right which is
the length and the last one sine C on
little C which is the length now what
you're looking at right now this line
here
it's a rule with lots of signs in it so
very imaginatively mathematicians named
it the sine rule don't forget Siim is
actually an abbreviation of the full
word which is saying okay this is the
sine rule now what's our telling us what
it tells us is there's this relationship
between all of the angles a B and C the
capitals in a triangle and all of the
lengths little a little B and little C
okay so just like we've been doing it
out in review questions you're like I've
got some information but I'm missing
something I could use trigonometry or
area or Pythagoras to fill in the gaps
in the same way the sine rule can be
used if you've got for instance stood
this one
just have a look at this part over here
if for instance you know two sides in a
triangle and you know one of the angles
if things are in the right position I'm
going to show you some examples in a
second if you know two sides and an
angle you can use that to find another
angle you can find the rest of them or
if you've got two angles and one of the
sides you can use that to find another
side now I'm going to show you what the
arrangements look like so underneath way
you've written that I'd like you to
write a subheading which is examples